LOUIS GRAY: Welcome back to
Google Developers Live at I/O
from Moscone Center here
in San Francisco.
We're here to talk
about Blink.
I'm Louis Gray, and
I'm joined by Alex
Komoroske and Paul Irish.
Welcome, gentlemen.
Thanks for joining us.
PAUL IRISH: Absolutely.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: No problem.
LOUIS GRAY: Real quickly, we
want to talk about Blink, a
brand new rendering engine.
I want to get you guys' take
on what's been introduced.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So Blink is
a new rendering engine.
It's based originally
off WebKit.
It's a rendering engine that's
open source, and it's using
Chromium and Chrome.
LOUIS GRAY: So you
said open source.
Is it a Google product?
Open source?
Help us out.
PAUL IRISH: I mean, it's
operated within kind of the
Chromium open-source
community.
So there's Chromium, which is
kind of the open-source
implementation of
Google Chrome.
And they're basically 99% the
same, with a few very small
differences.
But Blink is an open-source
project, and we expect it to
be used in Opera's
products as well.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Yeah.
So it's open source, and one
of our main goals for the
project is to be as
transparent, as open as possible.
So we're trying to
have as much of a
discussion in public channels.
We've already seen a lot of
really good engagement from
people from other companies,
from other organizations, and
web developers on these threads,
sort of providing
their feedback about features
we're thinking about
implementing.
It's been really great.
LOUIS GRAY: Right.
So how does a new
rendering engine
benefit consumers anyway?
Is it going to get faster?
What's going to happen?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So as
it starts out, it's
based off of WebKit.
So basically, as of a
month ago, it was
almost exactly the same.
Since then, we've been
optimizing some pieces on our
side, and it will continue
to get faster.
And over time, however, a
stronger, faster rendering
engine allows you to
do new things.
So it allows developers to
build better experiences.
It allows them to be faster so
consumers' webpages will just
appear faster and
do more things.
PAUL IRISH: One of the main
things that we focus a lot on
is speed, right?
And so when I'm scrolling a page
on my phone, I want it to
stick my finger,
and I want that
experience to be fantastic.
And with Blink, we have the
opportunity to make some
really radical changes to the
infrastructure of how a
browser's put together to really
deliver a fast and
awesome user experience.
LOUIS GRAY: One thing that's
really interesting.
You look at the web-- and it
was talked about today in
today's keynote--
we're on the 20th anniversary
of the
introduction of the web.
And one of the things that's
really helped the web grow and
just work on practically every
device is standards.
And so with an introduction of
a new rendering engine, is
this situation where web
developers and app developers
who code for the web are going
to have to make two versions
of their product?
What does that mean for
a developer's side?
PAUL IRISH: There's no
big real changes.
Blink is dedicated to
just supporting an
interoperable web.
And that's something that we
believe a lot, and it's having
a compatible, interoperable
web.
So for developers building
for the web, you
build to web standards.
You build just as you did, and
you can expect it to work.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: And I think
back many, many years ago,
different browsers were
very different.
I think in the past few years,
the different rendering
engines have gotten
closer and closer.
PAUL IRISH: A lot closer.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: A lot closer as
everyone really is taking
standards very seriously.
We're also very excited to
invest more in testing, so
helping write tests with
standards organizations and
other browser vendors
that all the browser
rendering engines can run.
And that helps verify that
these things are
interoperable.
And so the developers don't
have to write totally
different versions for
different browsers.
PAUL IRISH: In the past,
developers have known about
browser quirks and
things like that.
And over the past two years,
there have been less and less,
because browsers are running
the exact same tests, even
though they're different
products.
LOUIS GRAY: Right.
So this is the situation.
You used to have
modern browsers
and non-modern browsers.
Is Blink a cut above?
Is it going to be the
most modern browser?
PAUL IRISH: It certainly moves
fast, and it gets new features
all the time.
But you're going to get a
consistent experience when
you're coding to the
new features.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: The goal is
to build the best possible
rendering engine we can.
But what's great about the open
web is you have all these
different compatible rendering
engines, and so this is very
healthy competition
to spur innovation
throughout the ecosystem.
LOUIS GRAY: One thing we
talked about before.
Since Blink is still fairly
new, and we're talking a
little bit about the new
features that are
going to come out.
We expect the community to
respond really strongly.
One of the questions I have
around browsing is we have so
many people who are browsing on
mobile these days, relative
to the desktop.
How much did the advancement
of mobile usage of browsing
impact the decision to
look toward Blink?
And do you think that mobile
users can see the benefits of
Blink as quickly as desktop?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: If you saw the
keynote this morning, Linus
talked a lot about how the
future of the web is mobile,
and so we take this really
serious on the Chrome team.
Now, the reason that we started
Blink actually came
down to the fact that Chromium's
multiprocess
architecture is just different
than the other WebKit-based
browsers, and it led to
complexity in the code base.
And that was primarily the thing
that drove us to make
this decision.
But yes, we care very deeply
about mobile, and we're
excited about the different
kinds of things we can
experiment with.
LOUIS GRAY: And when
you look at the
complexity in the code base--
I remember when we launched,
and we had our initial blog
posts and the reactions
to it--
a lot of discussion was taken
to kind of getting away some
of the cruft or older code that
was available in WebKit.
How does that benefit
folks as well?
Is it just easier to
develop on it with
fewer lines of code?
I mean, what are we
getting away from?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: I want to point
out, actually, that
WebKit is an amazing
code base, and
it's an amazing community.
And what we were trying to
remove were pieces that just
weren't relevant to Chromium.
And so when you have extra stuff
in a code base that you
aren't using, that's
code that has more
surface area for bugs.
It takes longer to check
out as a developer.
It takes longer to
buil build even.
And so it was removing pieces
that didn't apply to Chromium
but were still very nice
pieces of code, like
JavaScriptCore, for example.
LOUIS GRAY: And you've mentioned
code and cruft.
One of the fun things I've seen
bump up in coverage of
Blink is vendor prefixes.
For those of us online who
don't know what a vendor
prefix is, what is it, Paul?
And why do I care about
a vendor prefix?
PAUL IRISH: Sure.
The idea behind vendor
prefix is a way to
kind of insulate users.
When browsers want to introduce
kind of a new,
experimental feature and they
want to be able to have a
little bit of freedom to maybe
change it in the future.
And then, browser vendors will
kind of work together,
standardize it.
And then, the prefix that's in
front of it will disappear.
It will graduate.
Now, that was kind of
the idea behind it,
and that sounds good.
But in practice over the past
few years, it's kind of not
worked out, and it's had
some kind of harmful
effects on the ecosystem.
So one of the things with the
introduction of Blink was that
we were able to take a policy
and said that we're not going
to be introducing any
new vendor prefixes.
It's painful as a developer to
deal with having multiple
vendor prefixes, and we're not
going to add any new ones, and
we're not going to introduce new
features that have this.
And this is a similar model to
what Mozilla with Firefox has
gone towards.
And also, the W3C CSS Working
Group has kind of said that
this is the direction that makes
sense going forward.
LOUIS GRAY: Now, Blink
is still fairly new.
I know a lot of people, often
when something comes out,
right away they say, how can
I get my hands on it?
And because Blink is an engine
and not an app, it's not like
you can just download Blink
and start playing.
So if you want to get your
hands on it, either as a
developer or as a user, what's
the best way to do that?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So again, from
the very beginning, it was
literally just WebKit.
And then, we've been developing
in a slightly
different direction.
And so all the newest versions
ever since April 4th, I think,
when we announced Blink, have
been using "Blink."
It's just that it's not really
that different yet.
It's getting more and
more different.
And so those versions will
become on the stable channel
of Chrome in a number
of weeks.
PAUL IRISH: The Chrome Beta has
Blink in it, and Canary
has Blink in it.
So if you want to try
it out, but--
ALEX KOMOROSKE: It's not going
to feel very different.
PAUL IRISH: No.
LOUIS GRAY: And as a Chrome OS
user, do I get access to Blink
as well, or is that
a separate branch?
PAUL IRISH: Yup.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Absolutely.
LOUIS GRAY: So I'm using
my Pixel here.
I use Pixel practically every
single day, as often as I can.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: I love mine.
LOUIS GRAY: And so one of the
things that's been really cool
for me for the Pixel--
I know we have a conversation
about that tomorrow--
is you're finding more and more
web apps are replacing
the things that I traditionally
had to use a
desktop for.
Is that part of also our
consideration, as we build a
new rendering engine, to enable
what's next in the
world of web apps?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Absolutely.
We believe very firmly that the
web platform deserves to
be as powerful as any other
native platform.
And so we've been pushing within
the ecosystem, within
the standards bodies, and really
supporting that drive
to make the web platform as
powerful as possible.
LOUIS GRAY: That's awesome.
Well, Paul and Alex, I
appreciate you guys coming
down today.
I know you have a very busy
Google I/O. Really one of the
hottest topics that's out there
for the web and for
Google in general.
For those you on the livestream,
stay tuned.
We have four more sessions
coming your way, whether
you're on the Android Channel,
Chrome Channel, or the
technical ones as well.
And we'll be back right after
those with more programming at
Google Developers Live at I/O.